hey
here we are again for our movie
retrospective this week
i have to say i'm uh not really
surprised that this one won the poll
uh on patreon which like i said if
you're not a patron you should
definitely go and
uh become a patron even giving as little
as one or two dollars a month will let
you vote
on not only the movie that we do on the
retrospective but also the topic like
for the upcoming week
and uh this was the one that won this
week by a pretty comfortable
margin this is the luchio fulchi
classic sort of the housewives cemetery
decent little flick
it is okay so this is we've done like a
lot of folgi films we did zombie like a
few weeks back
um and we've actually done the other two
movies in his
so-called gates of hell trilogy which
are the beyond and city of the living
dead
um this is actually the third of those
movies
they're not like obviously it's not like
a real trilogy but they're kind of
thematically similar although and they
have like a lot of the same actors in
them and kind of the same atmosphere and
stuff so you can see why they kind of
get
lumped together although this one is the
least
connected to the other two i guess
because like the other two at least had
a thing where
you know oh it's the gates of hell or
someone's opening a gate of hell this
one not so much
you know what i mean you kind of do the
same thing with some of those carpenter
flicks with the
you know what they call the apoc the
apocalypse trilogy they're not they're
not really
yeah and in the sense that like roman
polanski did like the apartment trilogy
which was like
um you know repulsion rosery's baby and
the tenant
yeah um just because they all took place
in apartment buildings and they were
kind of thematically like tied together
so that's kind of what you've got going
on in this situation um so house by the
cemetery
came out in 1981 and
although i don't think it was released
in the u.s and the uk until the
following year
um most people this one is actually even
among folgi fans this one's a little
divisive
because as much as you know people
kind of either love or hate italian
horror cinema for its
uh sometimes um questionable
logic yeah it does yeah i know exactly
this one
is pretty incoherent
i was watching it and i was like did i
miss something
yeah it's more about tone than it is
like uh
[ __ ] like you said a lot logical yeah
[ __ ] you know
[ __ ] well i don't know what man i'm
[ __ ] i'm kind of sleepy which i guess
like you know dario argento gets that
too but it's like this
this one um i feel like the beyond was
also kind of dream like city the living
dead also kind of dream like this one is
probably the most dreamlike of them in
the sense that
there's a lot of plot elements that are
introduced that seem like they don't go
anywhere
seems like they don't make any sense
what i was looking for was continuity
there's not a lot of continuity
but it doesn't really matter it's that's
kind of like a kind of like a ride at
the fun house or
you know what i mean there's not a lot
of continuity in what you see in a fun
house but you still go through it you
you enjoy it it's like that yeah and
it's definitely has
and i mean i think i told you because
i've seen this movie several times but i
haven't seen it for uh several years
it's actually on
um it's on shutter and it's on hulu it
might be on 2b too but i forgot to check
um i actually watched it on shutter but
i hadn't seen it for many years
so it's like i was glad to get to sort
of revisit it
and there's just something about this
one
even though i get that it doesn't really
make any sense i get that there's like
some
like weird goofy [ __ ] in there like the
bat thing yeah which we'll talk about
um i get that but there's just something
about the atmosphere of this one that i
really really dig
you can read into it and and make it
make sense
i don't know if it does like the whole
bat thing
he was stabbing the hell that bat as
he's going to step through his hand
a bat weighs a few ounces and this
dude's struggling with the [ __ ] bag
it was
super bad like it's like it's like it's
a 30-pound bat
i mean that's whipping his ass and it's
just that bad it is ridiculous
it had like really awesome jaw strength
is yes
i'm thinking kind of you know the way
the italians did
things sometimes is they just said we're
gonna show them next i think they were
just kind of making this up as they go
or they had some [ __ ] shot they said put
that scene in there
i don't know it's hard to say well what
happened with this one and i'm not
saying like i said of the three
quote unquote gates of hell movies this
is probably the least coherent even
though i'm not saying that beyond a
super coherence or city the living dead
was super coherent either
but they did seem to have like a more um
a more solid narrative than this one has
which like i said this one kind of goes
in like a couple directions
i think that what happened with this one
was that it had
several script writers that's what i
think it's gonna go one way and then it
went the other way and then it went the
other way well see the thing about it
okay so
dardonna sochatd who works on a lot of
lucio folgi's films he wrote zombie he's
written like most of his main ones
and i think that he was kind of
approaching it um he wanted to come at
it kind of like the turn of the screw
but also with like elements of the
shining because the shining had just
come out
and um they wanted to kind of do their
own spin on it so there are some things
there are some elements in this movie
that are very very shining like which
i'll get
to in a minute but so he wanted to do
that kind of thing with like this
supernatural
kind of thing and dardano also said that
he's like he was kind of inspired by
growing up
like in this big like creaky old house
that was by a cemetery
and he had to like you know walk down
like this little dark road like to get
to the house and everything
so he was kind of like bringing that to
it i guess lucio didn't like the script
or thought it should go in a different
direction so lucio made some
uh contributions they got like another
person and then they got like a script
doctor in there
and so they all kind of like threw in
their ideas
um and you can see there's like elements
of i even caught like elements of like
the omen
there's like just it seems like they
kind of just threw all these ideas in
there and didn't let they're like we'll
just worry about it later like whether
it makes sense or not you know what i
mean
um but that's not that that's not like a
criticism necessarily
because as we said before and if you are
really into italian horror cinema you
kind of have to learn to like
mitigate your um or you have to like
manage your expectations because like i
said a lot of times
they one they're all about the gore um
you know daario had this too where it's
like he just likes
a really cool gory set piece
and then you kind of like have to write
a story like just to kind of hang
around your gore so it'll kind of make
sense enough that people will watch it
i think a lot of it had to do with with
the italian
cinema experience back
in the 70s and 80s it's my understanding
that
the average italian family didn't have a
television during that period
what they but what they had was is that
italy was
filled with [ __ ] theaters and a movie
wasn't very expensive it's like a nickel
so people would go and see three four
five movies a week
maybe even more especially if they were
young
so these were kind of like in a way very
artistic television programs
yeah it didn't cost a whole lot to make
and they made many of them a year
and there was supposed to be a bunch of
rivalry and competition between the fans
of you know what i mean the fans of
these directors so fulton came out with
a movie you knew what movies were coming
and you had oh we gotta see that one
remember he did this one
so i don't they they didn't have to make
as much sense you're not talking about a
big
full-length full budget american
blockbuster that's not what these were
they were just entertainment you know
what i mean it was kind of like pulp
entertainment
and what the good italian directors did
is that they just made [ __ ]
look cool yeah cool look really
beautiful women
uh good-looking actors you know like the
men were good-looking in them too most
of the time
and it was just visually it was supposed
to be just like a visual experience
you weren't supposed to like overthink
it and i think this is
a good example plus two i think that
europeans
uh in general in their in their
filmmaking seem to have more
of a tolerance for surrealism yeah i
don't know
if i mean yes we have david lynch yes we
have like other things like that but i
do feel like american filmmakers are
kind of more loathe to just have
surrealistic
aspects to their films like whereas in
europe they're just like okay
you can be a lot more risky with what
you're doing
when when you take an account the people
that are watching this did not pay
twenty five dollars just sit down
they were i got ripped off yeah that's
not what happened
they paid a nickel to see the movie 25
cents maybe to see the movie back in the
70s
so the expectations of the audience are
very different and i mean really
like i said if you're going to go see a
fulchi horror film i mean and like and
i've said before like lucio folgi made
films in pretty much any genre he made
westerns he made comedies he made like
sex parses
he made all that kind of stuff um so
so he made giallos as well yeah jolly
sorry
for the all the italians out there but
um if you're going to see a fulchi
horror movie
you're basically you're going for the
gore i mean you know
and there's some really good gore set
pieces in this you know it's very bloody
it's like it's
it takes a while to get to you but like
some of the set pieces are really good
so let's kind of talk about the story as
as it is
and uh it does have a story that kind of
makes sense
but i kind of want to talk too about
like a little bit like of all the stuff
that they introduced that they didn't
really do anything with
you know what i'm saying so basically
what this story is about
it's funny that you said that well you
know didn't do anything but it's all the
dead ends
yeah and well in the sense that
i you know i didn't mean it to sound
like you know derogatory in any way
because i was just kind of like the
people that
people that review this movie that say
you know what about this and why was
this introduced and why isn't anything
so i kind of wanted to just talk about
they're [ __ ] with the script it's
more than one script they're
they're trying to weave a couple scripts
in together hey the old testament does
it
sure yeah yeah and people still read
that [ __ ] they'll read that [ __ ] yeah
there's
story of noah there's like we just
compared to lucha
the old testament of the bible that's
right to the old testament
you heard it here there's two flood
stories woven together in there
you pay close attention well there's a
couple creations and there's
two or three creation stories right yeah
which you know if you haven't read the
bible in a while is i don't know that's
where the italians were
maybe and that's actually a good way of
looking at it yeah because you know the
fact that looking at
the vatican and the heart of christ yeah
it's like all kind of like making
they're just they're just taking
aspects of [ __ ] they like we're like hey
we like this bit from the shining and
hey we like this bit from the omen and
hey we like this oh you like aliens
here's some more of that yeah oh yeah oh
yeah you like friday the 13th here's
some of that
yeah yeah although i like i said i will
say that friday the 13th
totally ripped off yeah you know the
italian marketing strategy was is
whatever was a big hit
at that time and you liked that they're
gonna give you some more of that
yeah or you like superman okay we'll
give you some more superman
they'll do their own spin they don't
know it's like they don't because people
like kind of
you know denigrate it by saying oh it's
a ripoff but it's like it's it's an
homage they're inspired by it you know
it's like oh let's make our own
superhero movie let's make our own like
haunted house movie listen
with aspects of it but we'll do our own
thing with it they're only a couple
steps away
from um turkey from turkish movies
okay well turn it up a little bit more
you got turkey
i mean turkey will straight up just rip
the [ __ ] off just take the character and
call it those like we'll put a dude
like a like a floppy dude like in a kind
of batman costume and he's batman
yeah they won't even like try to make a
different character
no batman with a steven spielberg score
from [ __ ]
raiders of los are playing and then in
the big fight scenes they got the damn
star wars theme playing like
copyright stop [ __ ] that yeah they're
like they do not give a single [ __ ]
turkey
they do not but let's go check out some
turkish films there are riot
go take go check out turkish spider-man
turkish spider-man target star wars
circuit turkish spider-man the
[ __ ] is a serial killer
basically he's a [ __ ] he's a bad guy
that's
and he kind of has the same outfit but i
think it's green it's green
it's it's red and green i think it's
right it's like the christmas
suit it's crazy it's christmas spider
man
all right so the story behind house by
the cemetery
so there's uh you you got your opening
scene this house
um which they did actually film because
it is set in new york city they did film
in new york city
some of it said like around boston uh
and they did film around there as well
so it is like where they're saying it is
um the interiors were done in rome
though so
there's this old house there's like kind
of a slasher movie beginning where
you know these there's this couple that
apparently we're making out of this old
house because that you know
[ __ ] abandoned houses get them hot or
whatever
so uh so her boyfriend steve has like
wandered off i mean obviously she's kind
of like running around the house being
like steve where the [ __ ] she goes
she's not funny and then she finds him
his [ __ ] brains all sticking out and
whatnot and then she gets stabbed
through the mouth like right through the
back of the
head and it comes out her mouth like the
blade so and that's the beginning
i don't know who these people are i
don't know if it has anything to do with
anything
but there we are so that's kind of the
opening scene then we get into the main
story which is
that there is this couple um
and they're the boyles and
that sounded bad when i said it but it's
b-o-y-l it's not like boils like
separating boils
so the the dad norman
one of his colleagues has apparently
flipped out
and killed his mistress and hanged
himself
in this particular house so norman has
to go to this town
which i guess is supposed to be outside
of boston it's called new whitby
which that's it's not a real place but
they're you know homaging
um you know dracula obviously
so he's supposed to go to this house and
continue
his uh colleague dr peterson he's gonna
continue his
research so they're going to stay in
this house
while he's doing that now this is also
the house where the dude
killed himself and all this other kind
of [ __ ] or he killed himself the library
or something i don't remember
it doesn't matter but um so he killed
himself in this town
so they move in they have this child
named bob
now bob is one of the things that
everybody talks about when they talk
about this movie and it's
it sucks because the kid the actor
seems like a completely good like child
actor and stuff however the person who
dubbed bob's voice should be
smacked because
it's just they just found i don't know
if it was it was a kid or if it was an
adult they usually get like a woman like
a voice actor to do like a little boy's
voice
um but it's just the it's just so so
irritating it's so
shrill of him just being like papi mommy
mommy mom you know just like it's
like oh my god please kill me it wasn't
as bad as i remembered like when i
rewatched it
but i remember like when the first time
i saw it i was like holy [ __ ] crap that
poor kid
and it's like now everybody's is gonna
think that he really talks like that
even
even though he doesn't because he's uh
italian so they move into this house now
one of the things that reminds me of the
shining
is that before they move to the house
they have like um
in their apartment in new york city they
have like a photograph of a house
which spookily looks exactly like the
house they end up moving into even
though they're not real clear over it's
supposed to be the same one or not
so bob keeps seeing this little girl in
the window of the house in the
photograph
and her little expression changes like
she's like oh like
like don't go there like don't don't go
inside don't go and stuff so she's
getting warned
just like um you know danny gets warned
before he goes to the overlook
uh because no one else can see this
little girl in the photo because his mom
is like you're [ __ ] high bob i don't
say anything and
you know just you're crazy so they end
up going to this house
and then you get like your kind of
standard haunted house kind of [ __ ]
there's like creaky noises like the dad
starts hearing like
what sounds like a baby crying or like a
little kid crying or something
they get this weird girl that shows up
named anne and i think it's the same
chick that was in
uh inferno i want to say was she an
inferno or tenta bray she's that italian
actress she's got like those real
intense eyes and his real dark eyebrows
so she shows up and this is the part
that remind me of the omen because she
reminds me of like
mrs bl mrs blaylock like when she shows
up like
hey i'm the nanny for the child of satan
and stuff so she kind of reminds me of
that
but that's one of the things that kind
of bothers me is that anna
or anne rather is like super creepy and
she's like hey i got sent over by like
the real estate age or whoever like put
them in the house
and uh you know to be your babysitter
your nanny and she doesn't really talk
like you can ask her like direct
questions and he'll
she'll just like stare at you and then
they do like a close-up on her eyes and
she's like looking at y'all funny and
[ __ ]
and she does like super sketchy [ __ ]
like they move into the house and the
seller has like you know boards across
it like someone's nailed it closed
and she's over there like prying the
[ __ ] off of the door
like she's gonna release whatever's in
the cellar
so she does weird [ __ ] like that and
then the dad's like hey what are you
doing or just like looks at her and
she's just like what i'm not
yeah and then he's like okay i'm
supposed to and then like he doesn't do
anything about it
yeah and what was weird eventually she
gets killed and really for no reason
and yeah she gets beheaded yeah and it
doesn't really make any sense
yeah because i thought i mean the first
time i saw this movie which was like
she's important to the story but she is
well i thought that she was like a
henchman
yeah like for the villain that's like
down in the cellar yeah
um but well maybe she is but then like
once she
served her purpose right like the the
demon doctor or whatever is just like
[ __ ] her
i think you're reading into it too much
i mean you can that's what i do
yeah i know you know what i'm saying
that's what i do we're reading into it
to try to forward this force this movie
into making sense
i don't think i don't think it actually
i think they were making it up as they
were going along really
yeah maybe i think she was going to be a
more important character but it got
edited out but then they were like [ __ ]
it yeah like i [ __ ] let's just get
rid of her we can't
the story can't go that direction it was
something like that because there was
one point where somebody gets killed in
the house while the family is out
and she's like cleaning up what is very
obviously a very large blood stain on
the kitchen floor
and the wife comes home who's played by
catriona mccall who's in a bunch of
folging movies she was also in the
beyond and she was also instead of the
living dead
she's a british actress i believe um and
anna's like scrubbing all this blood off
the floor and she's just like hey what
you doing and like all ann says is oh i
made coffee
yeah no one says anything about like
this huge blood stain maybe they thought
it was from the bat
i don't know but yeah so like i said
we're reading into it again
to try to make it make sense that's the
fun i think what happened is that the
movie was going to have a different
ending yeah and maybe they changed it
you know what i mean in mid making of
the movie i think and they said well we
don't cut
let's not cut her all out of the movie
we paid her
[Laughter]
she looks good so we're going to keep
her in the movie but we're going to kill
you off
now there's these guys living on in the
basement
you know they're kind of like a failed
attempt at immortality
which i don't see how that related to
her but she seemed to know about it but
like i said we're reading into it
i think the story was going to be
different i think like i said i think
they liked the idea of mrs blaylock from
the omen
like a nanny showing up to like look
after
right but the situation didn't know what
to do with that or they changed the
story
maybe another thing too that reminds me
of the shining and
that they don't really like flesh out
much
is that when norman comes to the house
like the dad when he comes to the house
to finish like dr peterson's uh research
several people in the town including the
real estate agent and
the librarian all this other kind of
stuff they see them it's like
man what you know you were just here
last summer haven't you been here before
so everybody like talks to him like he's
been there before
and then they also say that he has a
daughter and he's like look yo it's like
i've never
been to this town before i have a son
not a daughter um i've never had a
daughter so i don't know the [ __ ] you're
talking about
so it's almost kind of like they did a
thing with the shining where it's like
you know you've always been the
caretaker that kind of thing
but they didn't really like do anything
with that either
so but because i liked that aspect that
people kept telling him like
that he looked familiar could have been
the blaylock character was gonna be
like you said kyle kind of like a
caretaker
over the boy which would have been like
danny and she was going to groom him
into like a satanic thing
having to do with the house but i think
they changed the script
maybe they did and they got rid of her
and then and then like it didn't matter
they came up with something they thought
was better which were the dudes down the
basement and i actually think that was
a good idea it's just that they should
have coherently told that story
yeah because it's down in the back a lot
of the um reviews i've seen of this like
even people that like it because i do
really like this movie i have a lot of
affection for this movie it's like
it has like these really creepy like i
really like the little girl
mae uh who hangs out with bob except
nobody can see her because spoiler alert
i think
pretty sure she's a ghost um you know
what i mean the the one she was the one
that warned him like not to come there
um so i do really like this movie but i
do kind of feel like
so what ends up happening is that as
norman is like researching what the [ __ ]
happened with dr peterson
he finds out that dr peterson actually
was
um found out that the house he was
staying at
had once been owned by this doctor
dr freudstein which i love because it's
like frankenstein but also like freudian
so you know what i mean so it's a little
on the nose but okay
yeah so uh it he was like a victorian
era like late 19th century so he lived
in this house
and he had apparently and this is kind
of lovecraftian and it reminded me a
little bit of cool air
actually and i think fulchi wanted to go
like in a more lovecraft direction
um so you can see where that influence
came in as well um
where this doctor thought he wanted to
live forever
by basically renewing his cells with
um by killing people i don't know if he
was like eating the people or if he was
just like infusing
them somehow because he wasn't looking
too good i gotta say like when they
should be jerky like when they finally
do the reveal of like dr freudstein at
the end
it's like yeah he's looking a little
zombie-like he looks like he doesn't
really have a mouth it's kind of all
like [ __ ]
looking kind of dehydrated yeah looking
a little little jerky man yeah it does
kind of look like that
but see had had they had felchi told
that story from the very
beginning coherently and so there was
like a normal progression
you could he could have done a lot
better job but i'm telling you based on
what i saw
they changed the move they changed the
story
a couple times in the process of filming
this movie i think
well i feel like they were trying to
like it almost felt like fulchi was
trying to make like a mad scientist like
a lovecraftian mad scientist movie like
i said like cool air
which is what this kind of but it was
like the shining and the omen yeah then
they wanted some supernatural [ __ ]
i don't like that italian it's like kind
of like that italian ice cream called
spamoni
yeah okay you put some vanilla some
chocolate
it's a spoon it's strawberry you put
some pistachio ice cream
pistachios coconut all right
and some chocolate syrup on it with some
pineapple because [ __ ] yeah man it's all
and put some [ __ ] whipped cream on it
right and
that's the thing that the italian i
notice yeah spamoni
we just like all of this stuff so just
put it on put it all in there it's an
italian thing
sure it'll all work itself out well and
like i said
you they kind of like you can go with
kind of a surreal aspect like i said
it's a really cool like
surreal i really do have a lot of
affection for this movie because i
really like
like i said i especially like all the
supernatural [ __ ] like with with may
and like she's really creepy and like
her warning bob about everything
um but yeah it does kind of feel like
they were trying to do like a mad
scientist lovecraft thing
and then it kind of got they wanted it
they wanted to add like supernatural
elements like it's like you know from
like with the ghost girl and like all
this other stuff
and but the interesting thing about this
and i think maybe why
this also gets put in with um city of
the living dead and the beyond
is that full cheese movies particularly
his horror movies
always have like real bleak endings you
know what i mean they're they don't like
because i feel like a lot of
more traditional horror movies they kind
of end with a you know oh you know yay
like normality is restored like even a
lot of people got chopped up but at
least like one person got away and like
killed the killer or whatever
so it's like you know it's almost kind
of like they're restoring normality at
the end
whereas full cheese movies like they
always end in this really weird like
existential everyone's [ __ ]
gonna die and go to hell kind of thing
so it's like that's what happened in the
beyond that's what happened in the city
the living dead like they just ended up
in hell
and um in this one even though the
ending is
sort of ambiguous i think probably and
like i said this is spoiler alert if you
haven't seen come on this movie came out
like 1981 so
get with the program but um so they find
like [ __ ]
dr freudstein like down in the cellar
with all of the bodies and there's
heads and arms and stuff it looks really
good like all the door and stuff
that's really the best part of the movie
it is yeah like the the big like finale
yeah so they get down there like [ __ ]
norman gets killed like he just gets his
[ __ ] throat ripped out that looks
fantastic obviously
um and then [ __ ] uh you know the wife
cat i always call her a catcher animal
call because she's
i can't remember her characters in this
movie so it's just like well i know the
actor's
name because she's in a bunch of his
stuff so she's like trying to save bob
and they're trying to like he's trying
to get her out of the cellar they can't
get the door open because it's all
[ __ ] it's all
boarded up or whatever so the cool thing
too is that
they found like freudstein's like tomb
there's like a grave
grave thing like slab but it was like in
the floor
you know what i'm saying like at the
floor of the house it was like under a
carpet and stuff so that was like
another kind of freaky thing that they
discovered and so it was kind of cracked
from where the uh the real estate lady
got killed earlier like it cracked and
like her ankle got stuck in there
fun fact i'm pretty sure that's the same
actress that was in devil fish
which was like the italian ripoff of
jaws that was uh well one of the italian
rivers
they were trying it was on mystery
science theater that's why they were
trying to run better jaws by making it a
mutant jaws
it was kind of it was like a shark and a
squid it was like yeah it was like part
squid and like part it wasn't it wasn't
even just like a
regular shark it was like a megalodon
like a big [ __ ] huge
prehistoric shark they were like just
like [ __ ] that we're just going one up
man we're gonna put [ __ ] tentacles on
it and everything
yeah and it's genetically engineered um
so yeah
but yeah so like at the end when like
catriona is like trying to push bob like
out of this little [ __ ] crack
in the um in the grave very like
womb-like as it was or like pushing him
out
now catriona gets killed also by
freudstein because he just like kills
everybody because that's just how he
rolls now it appears that bob escapes
but when he comes out of the crack in
the tomb
he gets pulled up by may the little girl
and then suddenly everything in the
house is like
not shitty looking anymore he's just
like in the room with like all the dolls
mae has her little outfit on uh mary
freudstein is there who's grave we have
seen earlier
so i'm presuming that bob died
also but it was okay because
he could hang out with like the ghost
people now so like i said that's kind of
like the way they ended but i'm pretty
sure
i'm pretty sure bob died at the end i'm
just saying i mean well because he was
hanging out with the ghost
but in a way they were kind of like well
that's not such a bad thing
you know what i mean i don't know if
that's what
but yeah so like i said you really i
don't recommend
lucio folgi's movies to people
that are not um familiar with like
italian horror movies or who are not
like
you know i don't want to say like more
adventurous like horror watchers and
[ __ ] like that
i mean people love these movies for a
reason
but it's the tone you really have to be
in the mood to watch
and just be sure this does have a story
there is like you know the doctor and
the thing and he's trying to like live
forever and he's like slaughtering all
these people
and somehow that's like caused him to
live like 150 years or however
however old he is um so it does kind of
make sense but the supernatural stuff
seems like doesn't really like gel
with that i guess maybe he has like i
and i don't know what all the
all the kid crying is in the house like
i guess that's like people that he's
killed and they're just like haunting
the place
you know what i mean so that cut that
kind of works because he has killed a
bunch of people in that house so it's
like
is a visual medium it's showing you
things
and that's what the italians do they
just show you some stuff it's a trip you
don't worry about it too much he's like
wow
yeah you definitely just don't worry
don't worry about it yeah
and it does have a it does have a pretty
creepy tone because
it's showing you one thing but then the
soundtrack that's laid overs might be
kind of
creepy because it doesn't quite fit like
it might sound a little too happy for
the situation
or it might sound like i don't know like
it's piano and it might be slightly
off-key but
it's just different it's just weird
there's something unsettling about this
movie
the thing is is that this type of
this type of film worked really well in
the 70s and the 80s
yeah because of the technological
limitations of the time it produced a
certain tone
that we grew up watching and it's just a
trip
some of these same directors went on
into the modern era and tried to make
movies
using modern technology they just came
out like [ __ ] it just
you see remember the dracula one who did
the dracula one sorry origin dario
agenda yeah that's just like
that was awful awful okay and it's
because
that's because i think i think the
technological limitations of
those days actually added a certain
amount of [ __ ] tone or it enhanced it
enhanced
their with their weaknesses in a certain
way
when you gave them free reign to do
whatever they wanted and you gave them
some technology they just
no then you end up with something that's
asylum is doing better
asylum made better movies than that yeah
yeah
which like i said it's kind of a shame
and xylem doesn't make bad movies
not really they're just entertaining
movies like something from the sci-fi
channel and you watch them and you just
[ __ ] laugh well yeah
they're supposed to be what they are
they're good at doing well that's what i
mean he's at the center of the earth as
a [ __ ] masterpiece
they know exactly exactly what it is
what they're making and they're not
making any they don't have any
pretensions that they're making anything
good and really i don't think i don't
think these uh
classic italian directors could really
make an asylum movie it wouldn't come
out right
well the thing about lucio folgi the
thing about
um dario argento i was probably lucio
fulchi a bit less because he was more as
much as he had like an artistic vision
and he was like an artistic filmmaker
and i think he doesn't get a lot of
credit for how nicely shot like a lot of
his movies are like cinematography is
like really nice like the framing is
really nice
um you know it's it's not just like a
cheap cash grab but he was a little more
workmanlike he liked to
he wasn't like super into i mean he
liked horror movies but he made like a
bunch of different kinds
um daario more of an artiste i guess
but the problem is that you know once
you've kind of lost that spark or you
don't really have that vision anymore
or i don't know it just seems like maybe
as they get older they you know they get
kind of ossified yeah directors have a
half-life
i mean even some of the even cameron for
me i don't give a [ __ ] what dave
dave what cameron does this [ __ ] isn't
any good anymore it
was but they make money and they're not
hungry anymore and they get older
and they just although that's one thing
that i like i don't
mention before about surrealism that's
one thing that i like about david lynch
is that like the more successful hey guy
he just got weirder
so i just feel like the last feature
movie he made in land empire was just
like the most lynchy and it was the
[ __ ] weirdest
of all of his things yeah um so you know
and they did twin peaks the return and
that was like super weird so he just got
weirder and weirder
so it's like i really really like that i
respect that and it's still like and i
loved inland empire as [ __ ]
crazy and confusing and unsettling and
creepy as it was
i still haven't figured it out entirely
um
i you know i get the gist but like i
said a lot of his stuff's real
it's it's hard to make a good low-budget
movie
it is yeah especially with modern
technology
i think it was easier to make a good
low-budget movie
back in those days the best low-budget
movie i've seen recently
that was just piss-poor low-budget was
velocipassive yeah
and and it's because of the script and
they knew exactly what they were doing
and uh that's a [ __ ] awesome flick
awesome just
it knows exactly what it is and it gives
you exactly what you wanted
well yeah and you know we've said this a
lot of times too that
i really feel like yes visuals are cool
and yes
you know film is a visual medium but if
you don't have the writing
it's got to be the it was the script the
script and the edit
you don't have much of anything the
material that's in there is [ __ ]
genius although cool visuals go a long
way i will say that
but story story is always like the
essence of velocipastor gave you cool
visuals like
on a [ __ ] on on pennies
tiny tiny budget but yeah it was just
like it was the energy behind
it yeah yeah i mean you could tell they
were just having like the [ __ ]
fallen because they got eaten by the
[ __ ] the dinosaurs
and they and it's like they're right
they were playing football wouldn't it
uh i think so yeah
and i i mean i love the dinosaur too
like i loved the dinosaur in the ninja
fight that was just that was my favorite
dinosaurs and ninjas and [ __ ]
that was my favorite part yeah but yeah
seriously so like i said i don't
recommend
lucio fulchi movies to just anybody
that's just like a dilettante or you
know it's only
casually like horror movies you kind of
have to be really into horror
and you have to you have to kind of like
admire
what what where they were going with it
but like i said this one as much as i
love this movie you can see that they
had like a whole bunch of different
ideas and they were just kind of like
threw them all in the pot and like yeah
it'll just work itself
out which it kind of does because it
kind of comes across as this really
weird creepy but like i said if you want
like a [ __ ] linear
this story makes sense that's a germanic
concept you're not gonna
get the italians weren't into that
they're like an emotion emotion and
visuals that was it
yeah it was almost like a weird like
expressionist kind of
it's kind of like that or
impressionistic right yeah
but the thing is that was that was look
at troll two that's valid
that's what they that's what the
italians did that's that's that's
culturally their cinema was like that
and that is
and that is a delightful the most
coherent
of of them all would have would have
would have been
like the uh uh the man
with no name uh series yeah that was
pretty
i forgot the name of that [ __ ] what's
the name of that director uh
sergio leona yeah that's on tip of my
tongue
leone actually told coherent tales
but most italian westerns aren't
coherent
they're [ __ ] stupid too crazy
absolutely insane
like i said i think they're more into
like impressionistic or like
dream like yeah sort of logic which
that's a totally valid approach yeah i
think
you know whether you like whether the
you know the person watching it is gonna
like get it or like relate to it or like
it
like i said you really have to be in the
right frame of mind i'm going to say in
terms of italian director sergey leone
was the best he's best out of all well
yeah i think most people have said that
yeah
he's he's [ __ ] brilliant yeah so
but i i think it's important this this
movie though
i'm gonna say it's an important film if
you're into into horror if you're a
horror connoisseur you've probably
already seen it
yeah i would think if you're on the
italian stuff
yeah i mean you at least should have
seen this one
gates of hell um city of the living dead
zombie and the beyond
i mean those are kind of the ones and i
like i said and i mentioned this on our
on our zombie review i think that i'm
like a big advocate as far as folgi
films go i'm a
big uh fan of the psychic so i always
try to like plug that that's
that's his jello film but it also has a
little bit of a supernatural element
so i always kind of plug that because
that's kind of one of those yesterday
because it's kind of scattered brain
doesn't mean it wasn't a good movie
it was it's it's a good it's it's a good
movie yeah
can we and also it's important it's it's
been around
you know what i mean and people are
still talking about it nowadays like you
still get younger horror fans that are
still into it so like i said there is
obviously something
that a certain type of person responds
to if you've been drinking it's probably
even better
yeah well it's relaxing if i'd been if
you'd been drinking you probably would
have laughed yourself into a hernia at
that bat thing yeah
because you were sober and he was just
like he was dying
with that bad thing like i said this was
the first time he'd ever seen it i've
seen it
probably five or six he was fighting
that bat like it was a fifth like it was
a 50 pound dog
my foot well my favorite part of that
whole season on his head and he can't
get it off
my favorite part of that whole sequence
was that um the bat
actually first gets stuck in his wife's
hair and he just kind of stands there
going huh
yeah maybe i should do something about
that and she's like hey little help here
you know what i mean this [ __ ]
basketball player would have scared me
as a kid though if i'd seen it it
probably scared me
well there like i said there's some
really unsettling like [ __ ] in it yeah
like like that that scene where they
came rolling down the street yeah
like that and like well and they
foreshadowed that like with the little
girl mae like standing in front of the
shop window and that
creepy mannequin and like its head comes
off but it looks like a real head like
it's all bloody and [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that it was a lot it was a lot more gory
than
um than friday the 13th part one and two
they were showing them hacking that
woman's head off
and that's a pretty good effect it was
it this actually has really good
effects and it is pretty [ __ ] gory
like most of uh his movies were
but um and also you you know they
couldn't make
uh folgi couldn't make a agora film
without
some maggots in it so when dr freudstein
gets stabbed at the end all the [ __ ]
maggots come out and those are real
maggots
because the end of that the end of this
one kind of reminded me of that horror
movie what was what was the one where
all the dead people were coming out and
getting grabbing people and
i think there was a doctor behind it
body something or other
um [ __ ] i think it was an american movie
did we review it we reviewed it dead and
buried dead and buried
yeah there's something about the end of
this one kind of reminded me of dead and
buried
i need to see dead and buried again
that's why i think that's still on
shutter as well that's not italian is it
no
that's american right uh as far as it
had kind of like an italian
feel sensibility to it sure like they
had been like they had seen these movies
well yeah i mean the guy who was
bringing back people to bringing people
back to life wasn't it yeah
yeah yeah he was making zombies yeah
yeah so with this so it does kind of
have some
although that came out later yeah either
when did daddy berry come out we
reviewed it like i gotta see it again it
was 81
it might have come out the same year as
this or maybe a year or two later i saw
it dead and buried like on hbo when hbo
was new
and uh it was it scared me yeah it was
cool
that has some creepy [ __ ] in it too yeah
it must been about 13
yeah when it came out maybe 14 something
and like you said this also has some
like really creepy like imagery in it
and like i said to me it's like not even
though i mean the gore is really good
but to me it's the [ __ ] like pulling the
rug aside and
seeing that you know that tomb slab
um you know that little girl like in the
window like in the picture
like just i really like just real subtle
imagery like that like to me that's
creepier but i like the gore as well and
the gore effects in this one are really
good
so yeah if you haven't seen any of uh
fulchi's gates of hell trilogy
um we've reviewed all of them now this
is the third one so
go us but yeah uh check them out if
you're into that kind of thing
and that'll do it for this retrospective
and we'll see you on the next one
bye